what's clear to me reading the book is
that probably i mean this the your first
massive success
in a long string of massive successes
but the one i think that still feels
most near and near and dear to your
heart is cheers yeah
because
you helped formulate that show
um
and
uh with glenn and les charles you helped
make that show
and you're there and you're putting the
whole thing together and
you know this is you read the you read
your account of it and it sounds like
just the perfect
experience
all the way through
cast
writers
the way it was received once it's
beloved it just felt joyous the whole
ride
it was it was a wonderful experience
i met the boys i met i called my boys
the brothers
on phyllis they were story editors and i
was the permanent director the first
first year
and uh
so i met them then and then we
reconnected on taxi they were the
producers and i was the director of taxi
which was uh you know a wonderfully
funny show but it was just it was really
hard it was the first time i used four
cameras
and i had this cast that was
interplanetary
yes yeah
yeah and so
we went through a lot and at that point
you know jim brook jim brooks who was
one of the great comedy minds he was
going to great company rise was also
doing a movie so he wasn't there on
certain days
and you know there were other producers
who had certain ideas and jim edser so
it was it was you know the show turned
out fine but it was really difficult and
then we
we we started to talk about doing our
own show we had the same agent who said
you guys should do your own show and
uh in the book i talk about you know we
love faulty towers yeah
we thought about a hotel and then we
thought about the bar and then we
thought about a bar in barstow
and then we thought um
we do we're all sports fans so we're
going to do something in boston or
philadelphia we chose boston
and uh uh
we formulated these characters and the
original
conception of the show believe it or not
was sam malone the lothario working for
a woman
so the boys went off to write the script
and i went on my first honeymoon
and uh i came back home the script was
on my doorstep i read it
and i said you brought radio back to
television because it was so literate
and they had created this character of
diane chambers i had nothing to do with
it that was all
their work
and uh
it was
so smooth it was scary how the process
went we
you know we i knew about teddy because i
had auditioned him for best of the west
and shelley long had been out there and
people have been trying to get her
so they both fell in and
they they wrote the part for rhea
because they know ria from taxi and it
just went so smoothly and we had to deal
with nbc we got to do two pilots and
they would have to make one and this was
the first pilot
and we had big fans at nbc
grant tinker was brought in to run it
who brought me out to california and
brandon tardikov who was my close friend
yeah was there so
it went great and we you know we debuted
like in 70th place
nobody watched us there was no reason to
watch us but the rest is history you
know talking about cheers
you mentioned something in the book that
had an impact on me
you you guys thought of
there used to be a rule in sitcoms a
die-hard rule i'm talking about the
1950s 60s
that you always have to
the episode needs to end where it
started the world can't change i always
use the example of gilligan's island at
the end of the episode
they're still on the island they have to
still be on the island and that was a
that was just one of the rules
that was a solid rule of television for
a long time and then it starts to change
um and you're part of that change of no
we don't end up always at the same place
where we left off things
evolve characters evolve
people come and go
that felt like a
a huge shift
in television was that conscious oh yeah
oh yeah well at the end of the first
year
we have that great scene where they kiss
and we had to
we knew we were going to uh get them
together the second year
there was you know no more teasing we
had to get him together because if sam
alone
couldn't bet a woman in a year what kind
of stud is he yes
right right
so we were excoriated for that howard i
still have howard rosenberg's review in
the l.a times who said the show is over
yeah it's lost to magic it
but we said
we didn't care we knew
we had to be evolving we knew we had to
get them together and break them up get
them together and break them up and we
knew that
at the end of every year we would the
boys would write themselves into a
corner they'd break them up somehow and
then figure out in the summer how to get
them back together again or not
and it yielded you know i mean when
at the end of the second year when
diane flips out and goes into the looney
bin mm-hmm
she in the first episode of third year
she brings her doctor
into cheers
uh who has told her go back and confront
your demons
and the doctor was fraser crane yeah and
so
so that's that's what happened and you
know we finally
when shelley decided she didn't want to
do the show anymore we had to in essence
break them up and uh
and go back to the original conception
of the show when we sat around talking
about it which is sam working for a
woman yeah christie ellie comes in and
he has to work for her and i didn't
realize that was the original idea
but
such a good uh
such a good
flip and and putting them you didn't try
and recreate
uh
shelley long's role with someone else
how can you no you know who became diane
frazier yeah frazier did all the upscale
jokes yeah and bibi and uh lilith
sternit right they did all the upscale
humor so we didn't miss
diane in that way we missed her i mean
shelley without shelley long that show
doesn't get to year two yeah that's how
brilliant she was yeah she was amazing
the um the casting
and this is something else i want to
talk about
i think uh people don't often
realize
how difficult casting is and
you have to catch lightning in a bottle
and you have been around some of the
greatest
casting of all time
um
and and been part of it i mean it's just
stunning to me
you cannot
first of all finding kelsey grammer to
play
frasier crane
but then later on when you find david
hyde pierce
to play his brother when you guys when
you know when your casting director
finds this person
the casting is just
insanely good and and you can't imagine
there was no one else who could have
played
kelsey grammer's brother other than
david hyde pierce it was just perfect
and i mean i could go through a list of
all the
the different uh
casting choices but they're impeccable
kelsey kelsey owes his career and i've
told him mr john lithgow
because when when the boys wrote fraser
crane they went to lithgow
who would have been great
you know
and john didn't want to do a series then
and so we looked at a lot of people and
then
kelsey's face appeared on a
tape from new york city and we all
started laughing
he was 28 years old then
and
we brought him out and he
i think he lived in his car for a little
bit
until you know he he got going but
he was amazing he was a four he was a
four show arc
to get diane back in the bar but once
that first show happened we knew we had
a keeper right right and then when uh i
didn't i didn't create frasier
fraser was created by uh angel casey and
lee
who came to us and said they wanted to
spin fraser off
and their genius
was they took an actor kelsey grammer
and made him sam alone
and made david hyde pierce frasier wow
yeah
yeah
so that's how that that's how good an
actor kelsey is that he can go from kind
of a strange dude on cheers
uh to uh the center of a show yeah and
they could bring david in to play
frasier so who's more frasier than
frazier
no it's it's i mean
fascinating
how these things uh how these things
work i also i had heard this but i loved
reading
that um
when you guys were putting cheers
together
um
john ratzenberger came in and read for
the part of norm
didn't have a great audition
and he's walking out
thinking and you guys are thinking we
won't ever see him again and he turns
around and says
do you have a blowhard in the bar
we said no yeah so and he explained
right yeah he went into the whole thing
and and we said
wow
so we hired ratzenberger for the pilot
he's in the pilot because he's he talks
about the sweatiest movie ever made that
that whole rep
yeah yeah which was
which when we were in the office talking
about the show we heard
somebody at the paramount commissary
talking to his friend about what's the
sweatiest movie ever made so we stole
that
and uh because we had done a lot of
research in bars about bar conversation
everything like that so rats did that so
rats was hired for the pilot
he was not hired for the second show
but we realized that we missed him
so he's the only
permanent member of the cast that's
missing one show yeah he only did 274
out of 275
but amazing that he uh
he
he in the audition i mean anyone
listening right now is going to think
that's what i have to do
is turn to them and say do you have a
goalkeeper and you're what
you're a lion tamer
but he knew uh
you know it's a brilliant idea and um
just such a great
tool for the writers a know-it-all a guy
who knows everything or thinks he knows
everything is just a gift to the writing
room i know it was it was yeah and to
give him credibility
the great trick that we did was
sam would listen to him
and coach would listen to him
coach with wide eyes nikki would listen
to him and give him credibility right
and especially teddy if teddy listened
to you with sam the bartender then you
had credibility so that's
that's you know that was the great thing
about that show